in the lobby of Ramsay slow solutions
Joe and Tracy are with us hey guys how
are you
welcome welcome so you're here to do
your debt free screaming person we are
now where did you travel from where do
you live okay
hour and a half down the road then huh
all right cool and how much debt have
you guys paid off I love it and how long
did take you to pay off fifty nine
thousand okay making what kind of money
at the time Joe actually started and
paid off 32,000 on his own at fifty five
thousand a year mm-hmm we got married
our combined income was 110,000 mm-hmm
we cash flowed a honeymoon part of a
wedding a car and got gizelle intense on
a $27,000 loan in February no knock the
rest of it out for you well done what do
you guys do for a living
we're budget analysts of course you are
that makes perfect sense we're better
with our own money than the money we
worked now very cool okay so obviously
Tracy Joe hooked you into this as part
of the marriage plan okay so this is all
your fifty nine thousand or the debt
free home okay and so Tracy's over there
going okay Joe here's how you get the
girl yeah well she actually told me she
said your student loan keeps you
employed to got you a degree so I'll
help you pay for that the rest that
stupid stuffs on your own so I'm sure
how much I love didn't show how much I
wanted to marry yours there you go I
bought FPU and said I'll pay for it you
you just have to agree to go with me
okay
three weeks in he sold his truck whoa
yes took a $4,000 loss on it whoa drove
of a bader for well until it crapped out
what's the girl
a one-car family for about three months
Wow I'm cashflow to car which we love
because it's paid for and yeah really
ours and is the first car that I've
actually owned ever completely out of it
because you know why they have
drive-thru tellers at the banks and so
cars can see their real owners every so
often I tell everyone now that the bank
let me drive a truck for a long time
there you go that's a good plan
well good job you guys okay so Tracy
says here's how you get the girl you get
in that you get on the program and then
by the time you guys get married there's
nothing left but the 27,000 we got to
push pause just a second knockout the
honeymoon I got a couple other things
then you come back around and not get
off on those how it goes we didn't do
anything I tell everyone we're actually
going to teach our first FPU class Wow
yeah we were voluntold at church there's
of voluntold very cool we'll try to get
it up on youtube so you can get a hold
of it by there very neat and hey guys in
the booth make sure we make a note get
that get this video back out of them
very cool you guys that is awesome I
love it what a great story so how old
are you two I just turned 30 okay I'll
be 35 in July and you are debt-free you
make a hundred and ten thousand dollars
a year you know how to work together
yeah you know how to sacrifice to win
you can do anything this has been the
most valuable thing that we could have
ever done for our relationship for a
marriage and we are happy to be able to
have a platform to share with other
people the way that this has changed our
life we've been laughed at we've been
mocked we've been told we're drinking
the kool-aid and we'll stir the jug and
offer a sip to anybody who thought so
drink it by the glass so who made fun of
you my mother to find a point yeah just
say that in front of 10 million people
you'd been a lot of people that we get
Dave Ramsey debates on the regular about
credit card points some argue to require
miles and amazing wow you guys are on
fire this is fun so I want to go back to
something you said Tracy this is the
most valuable thing we could have done
for our marriage for our relationship
why I think it's really important when
you're married that you trust someone
and for me growing up in a debt-free
home it was important that I be able to
trust him with our household finances
and to know that if I decide to stop
being the excel nerd and turned that
over to him he can run with it and that
gives me a lot of peace and to know that
there is so much going on in the world
in our lives that could stress us out
this is one less thing we have to worry
about it's incredible we get our
paychecks every couple of weeks and look
at it and say this is all ours hmm what
are we gonna do with it yeah and we've
been able to you know just since
Thanksgiving bless other people oh yeah
in ways that to most people are small
you know buying dinner for a group of
people who've contributed positively to
our lives and that was a huge thing for
me just to see the joy that a free seven
dollar meal brought to them they can
never imagine what that did for us just
to be able to do those kinds of things
for people but yes to trust him
financially is that you can't put a
price on it's as big a step as it sounds
it is I was a I was a free the free
spirit the free spender I it didn't
matter what it was for a long time if I
thought I had the money I would and she
constantly said do you really need that
and now I find myself looking at her
saying the same
thing do we really need that and it's
you know it's come a long way when the
free spirit has made the saver look like
the free spirit it's pretty impressive
because I used to just I used to spend
like it was like a like it grew on a
tree and you went through the summer of
suck you went through living like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else when you were sitting
at the front of this Joe and even Tracy
after you got married you're sitting at
halfway through it looking at the the
mountain of debt was it as hard when you
really did it as you thought it was
going to be when you're looking up at
the mountain or was it easier than you
thought it was going to be to me it was
absolutely easier there were there were
hard times there were hard places there
were spots where I felt like I wanted to
quit got tired of doing it so to speak
mm-hmm but to just set your mind to it
what kept you from quitting her every
every day hurt she just looking at her
knowing that's where I wanted to be we
would make a conscious effort to say
okay we're kind of getting a little
burnout we need to set $50 aside to go
to a movie and dinner and I have no
shame I will throw a coupon on a table
as fast as anyone else so I can have my
nice date and not have to feel guilty
for it for weeks so those are the ways
that we know you grew up when a coupon
at your date dinner is romantic you got
and we actually both took on a second
job for a while we worked at a grocery
store for a while
just to kind of say okay all of this
full-time income is going towards them
towards the dead boom just like there's
a little part-time and you guys are
inspiring you're fun thank you you've
had fun doing this they're they're very
there's excited about their now they're
having a Toby Keith moment how you like
me now yeah
that's it so there you go I love it you
guys Joe and Tracy huntsville alabama
59,000 paid off in two and a half years
55 to 110,000 income and quite a journey
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
and the crowd goes wild as you they
would I love it what a great story what
a great couple this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year
so wish